let's get in the elephant at the recent
UFO photos released by nobody cares
because everyone's worried about
Carnival what I have a career in
politics I mean you would be a great you
would be a great president the United
States you'd be a great politician to
tone down some of the ridiculous things
I say
wrap it up you're nowhere near you're
nowhere near Donald Trump's level yeah
but what a problem he is for himself I
mean that that's the whole problem it's
like the whole narcissism I love the
story you used to tell about about when
he got elected when you were in prison
and ever all the prisoners reaction oh
they're so funny a lot of well a lot of
guys was perfectly happy yeah
so but the bulk of them and what's so
funny is that the Trump administration
has probably done more for prison or
prisoners than more for prisoners yeah
really
absolutely how so I you know you know I
got time off my sentence because of him
lots of people didn't I didn't get I was
supposed to get something like three
months or something Kanye West you okay
in prison they are he's eating eating
crabs these [ __ ] up even crabs even the
shell beaten these their shells okay yet
Donald Trump signed one of the bills
inside the bo p used to short you about
about seven days every year mm-hmm and
so what happens all these other
administrations like we're gonna fix
that we're gonna fix it and they never
did Obama had it had two terms never
fixed it mm-hmm Trump comes in within a
year or so he's like yeah [ __ ] it let's
fix that [ __ ] what do I have to sign
write it up sure no problem boom guys
are getting form four months off their
sentence six months a year I was
supposed to actually get several months
but I don't was already in a halfway
house by the time it happened I never
getting a few weeks mmm well I was
actually close get a few months
but yeah so I mean it's it's look
they're there let you know they're
letting tons of people out right now cuz
of the coronavirus yeah in other
countries though in this country Oh in
this one really half the women in the
camp and all the camps if you did fifty
percent of your time in the in the in
the camps are in Coleman they were
letting the girls go Wow
if you did fifty percent of your time
and you were nonviolent well most women
have nonviolent crimes so they're almost
non vile almost all in line by line yeah
so yeah guys are getting out left and
right
also on compassionate relief he also
signed in the Second Chance Act he's
signed up but a ton of bills look it
just doesn't make sense to keep guys
keep some guys some nonviolent guy give
him twenty years and keep him in jail
for twenty years because he filled out
some paperwork and and and you know some
people lost some money and that's
horrible
great get him out let him start paying
and paying it back ya know we're gonna
give him twenty I feel like they could
have liked taking you and made you like
an intern for this for the CIA instead
maybe I got like an unpaid like an
unpaid intern for it like a low paid
intern for the Secret Service I mean I
don't have probably should have been
doing something productive other than
just sitting in prison right with that
first of all you realize how much
cheaper and once you've done that for a
certain amount of time you know it was
cheaper it is to keep someone on
probation than it is the kink are
serrated them how much cheaper I don't
know it's got to be significant under
the actual number but I do know that you
know I'm paying for all my own my own
bills and everything instead the Bo P
playing it's probably only a couple
thousand dollars per year as opposed to
thirty thousand dollars to keep you
incarcerated because thirty thousand to
keep me incarcerated in the federal
system probably only a couple grand to
keep you on probation a lot of people
are saying Trump 2020 in the chat what
about we need Amedeo when is Amedeo get
out of prison what does he get out of
prison
neither Amedeo mat Cox bill he's been
eating those [ __ ] gummies those Hondo
milligram gummies and those crab one
hundred milligram crab legs
crab legs just leveled me back out to
Blaine's zero there's little there's
literally just started all over there's
crab fragments all over this area right
now from Shane eating all those crab lid
you ordered it no I'm not complaining
I'm just saying you paid for all this
great listeners paid for with alright
let's wrap this up
wait we got to find out when Amadeo is
getting out when are you getting out
he's gonna do this podcast this weekend
it's so little soon with our insight
connect Johnny Appleseed oh thanks for
calling in now what a coincidence that
he calls it how good I'm home in that I
think we planned that but we didn't it's
a conspiracy that's a close friend bucks
what twist Matt leaves Danny and goes to
work for a name I can't mention look so
he gets out July 26 2028 so we need
Amedeo president 2028 2028 Amedeo for
president 2028 yeah that's perfect - we
got a vote for I'm sorry Emperor you're
right Amadeo for Emperor 2028 nice
that's the way to go we need shirts and
then we need they different shirts with
different quotes alright we can we can
get make it make that happen for sure
that's got to be that's got that's you
Thank You Kyle Roberts we got enough
money here for you to like start running
and you know start a campaign sort of
campaign get some commercials out get
some yard signs going this has been a
great podcast Matt I hope you enjoyed
your crab legs and your potatoes and
your corn and your bull yeah what do you
think about Luke so funny now what do
you think about me and Luke for the
first time I think looks great what do
you think it's a privilege that
replacing Ken Hatrack with Luke yeah
what do you think have yet to have him
not get [ __ ] up the whole look at not
you know what kill every time we do a
podcast you always make sure that he's
gonna be here honey we need a sounding
board your your your - you know pencil
protector you know you're a little rigid
yeah yeah you're you know we need
somebody to kind of be like
because like I prepared for this here's
my questions and let's answer them he
never prepares for nothing that's the
worst part you always just kill me
it kills ya he's completely unprepared
it kills me that the whole the whole
sitting next to you somebody call
somebody will send me an email or
something and be like hey man can you
know okay you know and I'll swap a
couple of comments and yeah I end up
talking to him [ __ ] bro it's so amazing
to be talking to you and it's so this
and I just feel like I'm just some
douchebag that just got out of [ __ ]
prison and you're like I'm like a huge
fan of and I add my email this crazy
emailed this dude he responded to me
right next thing I know I'm an Internet
superstar that's that's Danny maybe an
Internet superstar and he has no problem
taking complete credit for it and all
the money that's been given in the chat
yeah and you've been on flat TV you've
been a hot what's the other one value to
a payment
some some some rich weirdos flee you
down to the Cayman Islands for like some
some [ __ ] rich dudes and flew him
down to Puerto Rico to give like a
two-hour 7 o and you know what happened
well I didn't tell you this this listen
this is I think it's there and deputy
right serendipity it's where it's like
wow it's like everything literally a
couple days before that I get a phone
call from someone who says how much they
pay you a thousand bucks now it in
Puerto Rico yeah 1600 and the plane
ticket and I stayed overnight at a very
nice hotel and they were great ok so but
this is the cool part listen to this the
cool part is this is that a couple days
beforehand I get a phone call from
somebody saying hey look I know this
this lawyer I just met this lawyer he
this everybody knows him I don't think
so no okay so here's well I'm not gonna
stop this time so what happens is the
law I know a lawyer entertainment lawyer
I tells him I told him about you I
checked it out I read the whole thing he
went to the website he checked out the
website then he called somebody they
represented okay great so they talked to
this woman named and she's a producer
and so he goes she wants to have a
meeting with you she's checked out your
channel
all the stuff she wants to talk she does
a bunch of movies and I said okay cool
and I go what he they when can she talk
to you and I said well she can't talk to
me on Tuesday or Wednesday whatever it
was I said because I'm going to Puerto
Rico and he goes you know what she's in
Puerto Rico right now oh the Netflix
lady yes and I was like well I'm gonna
be in port here so she's a puerto rico
right now where you going i go will san
juan he goes let me make a couple calls
they make a couple calls next thing i
know they call back they go she can meet
you in puerto rico she's gonna be there
anyway at that night she's shooting all
day and that at that night she can meet
you so i go and i meet the guys right
they pay me in the sixteen hundred bucks
i get into an uber i then go to san juan
high they may you
Zillah Zillah Szell Szell yeah yeah yeah
joe like chase QuickPay
yeah so then i go i get an uber I go to
the Vanderbilt hotel nice [ __ ] hotel
I could have live it in the bathroom
amazing so I meet with her I spend three
hours with her and that's where I met
the guy Kevin the guy from Entourage
Kevin Kevin Connolly Kevin Connolly he
plays E in Entourage
so I meet him he's there I meet her I
meet her or the other producer we talk
for three hours she and so we talk for
like three days she's super cool and so
we have dinner and she ends up saying
look we're gonna look over your content
I like you I like the content that I
seen I definitely think we can do
something I'll be in touch I was like
okay I don't think much of it so but you
know I don't think anything's gonna come
of it so what ends up happening is like
two weeks later I sent her an e tax and
she goes oh my gosh we were just look
actually yesterday we were gonna call
you if we look over your stuff I needed
to call you up so glad you so I get on
the phone I talked to her a couple times
a week later I talked to her she hooks
me up with this other guy and with this
guy from zero gravity and then zero
gravity comes in and they say look we
want to represent you on these two
stories and we'd like to manage you and
that's where I'm right now we've had a
bunch of phone calls and I'm supposed to
sign a contract with them to manage them
stuff and you only got to pay us five
thousand a month we take 30% nobody's
that's none of that's happened that's
Danny's thing um so yeah so it that was
a great that was a great trip
and that's that's uh I think this thing
I think those like producers are so
weird especially a thing of the past
like to be like an omen Netflix producer
yeah let's meet let's go have lunch it's
Natalie we can talk about our new series
that we're gonna produce me you know
saina saina shopping agreement with us
and and we'll try to pitch you into HBO
and you know you telling me that if
you're telling me that if a producer
from Netflix or from Blum House came in
and said look we want to turn your thing
and tour this we want to you'd be like
hey enough with you I'm not interested
in Netflix series I'm Danny and I'm
doing my thing and I'm not come on you'd
be like well let's talk about well let's
think let's look at this from a
different perspective okay let's say
that this is actually a successful
podcast okay okay Sony just drop 90
bucks and says Danny has to eat one of
Shane's old crab legs pick up pick up
the show I'd like to make a point
yeah pick up under $90 let's pretend
this is successful
god damn you was that Cowell Roberts who
gave that $90 yeah oh you [ __ ] mommy
pick it up it's miss sniffing - come on
the podcast and I'll [ __ ] I'll do it
let's pretend that this is what as a
successful podcast on YouTube half
Koji's it'd be successful if you had
some crab legs say this was for example
a Joe Rogan stop podcast I got every
episode a million views right Joe Rogan
have a crab why hasn't he taken a deal
with Netflix or one of these things see
million dollars a year dot dot dot
there you go he didn't sign the deal
with the devil he makes his own money he
[ __ ] creates his own content he owns
everything that he does he has all of
his own subscribers he doesn't have
anyone wearing a tie telling him what
the [ __ ] do I understand but you you
you think that that's what's gonna
happen here it's not that I'm not know
the point is I'm not asking I'm here it
happened with it would happen with
someone that was on his level he
controls everything he does right he's
not gonna have no one like Netflix can
offer him anything that's worth anything
because he may fit if it was Joe Rogan
Rogan and me he made $100,000 a year
Netflix came in I think he'd take it
yeah but the point is they wouldn't
offer him that if he was only making
$100,000 a year cuz it would have enough
viewers to make any kind of difference
on Netflix his [ __ ] scale on their
meter it wouldn't it wouldn't do
anything why am I not you me yeah you're
not understanding you're completely
missing it I am I am missing it you are
you're I'm saying that you have an
opportunity to have a Netflix series god
knows what they're gonna pay you God
knows the exposure it's gonna be it
would be amazing exposure it could
probably be a great payday it might run
for 10 years look I think it's cool for
people that made the tiger King
documentary because they spent five
years filming and producing something
that never got never saw the light of
day right nobody saw it but for example
if you're someone who's creating stuff
that's being published all the time and
you're kind of like building a brand and
you're building an audience but you're
are you building that brand to
ultimately kind of go to the next level
or just continual yeah definitely go to
the nicely but always you're always
trying to go to the next level is the
next level what the next level is just
the next is gaining more of an audience
gaining building a stronger brand that's
the next level is just constantly trying
to grow what you have and make it
stronger and make it bigger so if
someone said hey we like what you've
done with with deck hands with deck
hands and we're thinking about taking
some of those characters we'd love to
turn that into a Netflix series about
guys with alcohol problems who work on
boats and we think that'd be great and
would you be interested and work
with us on some type of a series a
different that's different because that
kind of like a one-off series that we
did
[Laughter]